chocolate spread made in the Ivory Coast
every day the company simois produces
thousands of jars head of production
Adama coulibaly is proud of his product
two years ago the company invested the
equivalent of 8 million euros in the
Chocolate Factory
a chocolate factory like this is
invaluable to a country such as the
Ivory Coast it's a shame that the
largest cacao producer has never been a
chocolate country that's unfair
but luckily someone is changing this
with this factory for a long time Africa
has only been a source of raw materials
but change is necessary to make progress
we need to add value to what we produce
and we need a growing middle class plus
more young almost all the ingredients
used here come from the Ivory Coast
cooperatives buy the beans for German
Development Minister GAD Miller it's a
prime example of how to add value to raw
materials Germany's Marshall Plan for
Africa is supposed to strengthen the
private sector and create new jobs -
have done with Africa the Marshall Plan
for Africa is very well implemented here
it's really important to add value and
increase salaries at the beginning of
the production chain in developing
countries in this case on the Ivory
Coast cacao plantations this generates
income and provides incentives for
development in common on damodar can't
week long however there's still not much
demand for chocolates in the Ivory Coast
itself the firm Simois estimates that of
ourian's only consumed 30 grams of
chocolate per year
Germans consume almost 9 kilos a year
above chocolate is about 2 euros in
supermarkets chocolate spread starts at
50 cents
still too much for most Ivorians
nonetheless companies like simois are
counting on the growing middle class in
the country the idea is simple
the more money people make the more
they're going to spend on chocolates
introducing Ivorians to the world of
chocolates that's the challenge for
Adama and his colleagues but with the
new production plant planned for April
the chocolate firms future is already
looking sweet